if you're going one to ten you can't
sell anymore right you need someone you
need a team of people who are selling on
your behalf so it's you have to not only
be able to sell you have to teach people
to sell you have to know how to recruit
sales people you have to know how to
manage sales people you know how to send
salespeople and continue to get them
performing right and that's a different
skill right we know how to sell how many
people be like god i close these people
so easily and no one else can sound like
me it's like it feels good but you're
still way poorer than somebody's got 20
sales guys closing for so like just get
over it like there are people who are
better than you at closing because all
they're going to do all day is close you
still run a business so you got to stop
selling it's my opinion that 10 to 10 to
30ish is you have to give up the
marketing you have you really have to
get beyond that and then at going 50
plus you know 30 to 50 plus it's like
you have to give up the leading which is
difficult